Laurie hey Howie Mart will hunt the
Brixton thank you okay you've handed all
your personal items into the gate there
oh yeah phone and phone and everything
like that I remind you to do that every
day that you can okay let's go inside
officer mark Westgard is taking me into
the heart of the prison here
the prisoners are kept in their cells up
to 21 hours a day if he tries to mug her
putting one in his place I want that no
problem certainly it to be made fun of
by him or anyone else can be fierce the
people days working with ya
[Laughter]
I think you would leave a few people
along the way that's how it goes you
know only the strong survive
[Music]
the prisoners are housed in five
separate wings I have no idea who I'm
gonna be working with if it come here
change the world I don't think you will
and I don't think long term it's gonna
gonna be a winner
how many
[Music]
90% of the criminals on this wing have
serious drug or alcohol problems
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's lunchtime
the prisoners are let out their cell for
a few brief moments to collect their
food is a chance for me to go
face-to-face with some of my potential
workers
[Music]
obviously you signed up yeah yeah so you
signed up yeah things are uh yeah you
finding yeah not really
can you scream away yeah good that have
a gun mr. Jones
last time he cooks tonight in neutral
was it yes be able nice they go down
well it's easy to forget some of these
prisoners are here for serious offenses
for years for doom one
event
they found a shotgun under your bed
[Music]
some of these people are quite dangerous
you might get people screaming and
shouting
because you're you know you're famous so
they might they might wherever pop
please don't rustle no no we will deal
with them they're not like this
[Music]
the mood has suddenly turned an offender
is kicking off all I can hear is my name
[Applause]
it's amazing how quick it kicks off like
that all of sudden thank you no
heartbeat or maybe a silent next minute
like a potential riot these are men
under pressure
I won't men are under pressure they can
do bad things what kind of things in
Abidjan warrior I'll go out a fire
throwing something could be
tough job Tony the enormity of what I've
taken on is starting to sink in in 2010
there were over 14,000 assaults in
prison and nearly 3,000 attacks on staff
recently someone rather closely just
died jump to bind brush melted in and
spit that's the kind of things that go
on you can feel it is like a sort of
huge wave of pressure in there almost
like is bursting is so intense didn't
seem at first where we are I'm here it's
just getting stronger and stronger